confession to make
you ready bud I'm so ready I want to be
careful how tall with this microphone on
okay where I'm sitting right here this
is exactly where I have my first onion
burger oh holy crap
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
again here we are but this time we're in
Oklahoma this time we're at an RV in the
burger RV
listen it's not the best RV but it's our
RV it's our RV
we're basically two hours south of
Oklahoma City but four hours north of
Dallas and look at look at the open road
in front of us dude it's so wide open
yeah you can see for miles miles a
little bit miles Oklahoma is one of my
favorite places to eat burgers because
you're gonna find burgers in the state
that are totally unaffected by a Time
Trend their primary source hamburger so
it's also you know it's one of the
places where I had one of my greatest
hamburger experiences the Oklahoma fried
onion burger yes but if you look at a
map right okay there's the burger Bell
which runs from All the Way North in
Wisconsin it goes down south to Texas
and some of what sort of the South
middle of that belt is what I call the
burger Buckle okay and the burger Buckle
is that we're hungry let's go I cannot
stress more the importance getting on
the road getting out there eating these
primary source Burgers holy [__] watch
out yeah
whoa the Rattler
sorry the whole Road there today we're
going to three places right okay we're
going to the mirror store first way out
in mirrors Oklahoma far they make a
burger man with Longhorn beef then we're
gonna go to a place called Johnny's in
Oklahoma City they actually have two
burgers we're gonna have there the
Caesar burger and one of my favorites
the Theta burger and then the third
spot's gonna be to the birthplace of the
Oklahoma fried onion burger we're gonna
hit one of my favorite spots since Diner
in El Reno Oklahoma and I cannot wait to
go back so it's been a long long time
Dad I'm excited for me too opening shot
of the scene that I shot for hamburger
America's right here a lot of history
for me here way do you see the mirror
store there's literally nothing like it
I've never seen it up there but there it
is
mirrors store and restaurants
foreign
[Music]
have you taken me I've taken you out to
the middle of nowhere are you gonna
whack me is it very different yeah it's
a cobbled together building this place
is a very very deep history very deep at
the end of the 1800s somebody discovered
gold some enterprising young person set
up a a building here that was there just
to supply the miners with equipment it
makes sense they found it right away
that it wasn't it was Fool's Gold it was
pyrite they actually abandoned the
building at some point it became a
grocery store it became a post office
the good news is it's not just a pretty
place it also they also have a great
burger we get two burgers coming right
yeah the original mearsburger which is a
half pound of Texas Longhorn beef cooked
flat served on a seven inch bun it's a
custom made bun okay served in a seven
inch pie plate also we also have the
seismic coming that's a later Edition so
hungry hello hello
onion rings onion rings of course
silverware if we need it mirrors
cheeseburger you put them down we're
going to show you okay they're nicely
into quarters
[Music]
okay look at the side the seismic is the
size of my head yeah it's outside your
head it's a pound of beef with a pound
of beef but it's also cheese onions uh
bacon jalapenos on there it's hot like a
pie it's served in a pie too yeah
look at the cross section of a bad boy
Texas Longhorn beef is lean those are
actually grass finished animals
no no grain the best thing about this
burger by the way came from their Ranch
which is right nearby they raised all
the animals for all the beef in the
restaurant
Margie bought this place they managed to
somehow in anonymously preserve the
history of the place you know they could
have torn it all down and started over
for sure for some reason I think they
they had the sense to hold on to
tradition and keep it going you know I
kind of I appreciate that I've got a
nice sear on it is this Smash Bro wow
I gotta tell you it tastes kind of like
a crossfit a Texas Burger and LA Burger
because all it's salad very much so
because there's bacon and bacon yeah
there's jalapenos yeah lettuce tomato
I'm on trade should we trade oh my God
oh wow what happened it's all about the
beef the reason they call this the
seismic is because at one point they
used to have a seismic monitor in the
front of the restaurant we're on the
fault line out here right that's what
they're first looking at our earthquakes
out here the only place they can plug in
the monitor was here in the restaurant I
forgot how good this burger was it's one
thing eating burgers yeah it's another
thing tasting history we should do is go
check out the cattle ranch yeah you need
a little break between Burgers right I
need to know where my burger has come
from yeah it's good to know
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
Diana's album
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Bible story hot dogs and prizes that'll
get me to go to church
if we make it back to Oklahoma City with
the back still attached on here I'll be
[__] amazed
[Music]
Rick Haynes is my name co-owner was my
brother of the Johnny's we started in
1971. it's been a run yeah
so Johnny is my father he was with a
well-known hamburger place called split
tea and he was with them from 1953 to
1971 and in 71 he branched off and
started Johnny's on his own Theta Burger
is the most popular Burger in Oklahoma
if you go all around Oklahoma City today
on any kind of restaurant that serves
Burgers you probably will find a Theta
Burger we think we're the real Theta
Burger it's made with our hickory sauce
we call it Johnny sauce between a
barbecue and a smoked sauce is what I
would go with you know soy sauce
Worcestershire sauce tomato puree and
then lots of seasonings and the deal is
we just cook it for about four hours we
make a season Burger it's made with our
own Caesar dressing that we make and we
toss it like a caesar salad and we put
it on a burger and it is great Messi is
all get out
you know it's my dad's Legacy that's
very important to us that's why we're
still here that's why my brother and I
still I'm 64 years old he'll be 70. we
still work in the business every day the
history of Johnny's is is very important
to our family I've got a confession to
make okay I've never been here before
ready whoa place I've never been which
is okay people think oh you've been
everywhere I feel like you have it's
kind of embarrassing I should have been
here because this is one of the most
historically a significant hamburger
restaurants I believe in Oklahoma tell
me why there's a reason why it's because
there's a crazy lineage to the sauce
they have and they have this red sauce
okay it's it's a like a barbecue sauce
hickory sauce like uh apple pie exactly
okay you realize it's actually a lineage
that connects this place to The Apple
Pan to a place in Tampa called the goody
goody of the split tea which is also
gone it was right up the street here
they're holding onto two very important
traditions in the hamburger world this
is what I'm learning on this trip is
that like Oklahoma is like the birth of
a lot of things that are trendy right
now on Burgers right hickory sauce being
one of them yeah and now we are at the
birthplace yeah first time ever together
yes exactly that's first that's pretty
well Burger show first guys so we're
here to talk about two very important
hyper Regional Oklahoma burners oh
that's my language the Theta and the
Caesar Burger Theta it was named after a
sorority in Norman Oklahoma at OU wow in
the 50s they came up with this burger
that has shredded American cheese got
any sauce of the sauce that the state of
sauce okay back then pickles mayonnaise
on a toasted button that was it huh it
was it's really good it's a great burger
second Burger is a burger called the
Caesar burger what I understand you can
only get it here what's Caesar about I
don't
I'm catching you at this really rare
moment where you've never been to a
place before I've never been to a place
before and we're gonna try for the first
time pure uncut raw reaction towards
Burgers Raw it's gonna be amazing yeah I
can't wait I'm starving let's eat let's
smell it hello guys how are you today
hey Rick welcome to Johnny's this is
Rick Rick nice to meet you Rick is Rick
is a very important guy in the world of
hamburgers I don't know about that but
thank you you're one of my hamburger
Heroes because it's what you're doing is
you're you're upholding a very important
tradition and it's very important to us
so yeah we feel like the integrity and
the equality are still there after 52
years well thank you for guys for coming
that's easy thank you thank you thank
you Caesar Burger I'm gonna hold the
season burger for a minute data first
the sauce I can tell you right now
[Music]
it's almost like a smoky tomato sauce
those are some serious shreds of cheese
too they're not choking oh
holy crap
[Music]
I just went like yeah so I have to try
real don't taste that this is key yeah
that's very unique and the amount
there's nothing wrong with Alberta it's
fantastic it is phenomenal okay the
Caesar Burger that's straight up Caesar
Caesar sauce with some lettuce there's a
Caesar salad on this
um
wow yo it's basically a Parmesan
cheeseburger with some lettuce and
that's fantastic that is totally totally
unique I've never had them no cheese no
cheese
in the dressing
I've never had anything like that before
in my life wow bro this is a power of
lunch
you don't have time to eat a salad and a
burger separately you put it together
so next one last stop yeah going to the
place where well
it All Began for me
okay I'm excited
but you must be really excited you're
getting Goosebumps it's been a while
since I've been there yeah and it's been
hunched when was the last time you went
uh probably six years ago damn it's time
it's time yeah let's go
[Music]
onion Birds Onion Burgers
pulling into El Reno right now
there's the green elevator over there
look at that picture huh wow wait to see
downtown it looks like a Norman Rockwell
painting oh man classic Americana at its
best at its finest right here it's
Johnny's the other Chinese
there's Robert's right there hey Roberts
ready for this one
the hair on the back of my head standing
up right now
this is right here in that corner right
here was where the uh where the bank is
now that's where the first Onion Burgers
were made oh wow and they're SIDS
so they're all within a block of each
other that is so cool
you ready to bed I'm so ready this is
this is it I mean I've been in thousands
of hamburger joints this is one of those
places arguably top three most important
here we go let's go
[Music]
ready
how you doing good to see you you're
looking pretty good you're exactly the
same yeah it's my friend pleasure to
meet you I'm sorry Alvin can I ask where
you're from I'm from Los Angeles Los
Angeles yeah from Oklahoma thank you
never it's first time yeah I'm excited
he's kind of special to me
what changed my life I mean this is yeah
this is really the place that uh
Champion I owe you I owe a lot to the to
this town do you for sure I really do my
name's Marty Hall we're at El Reno
Oklahoma at Sid's Diner on Route 66
Highway 81. Sid was my dad my dad passed
away before I built this Diner but I
wanted to name it after him but that's
not easy to do he put your daddy's name
on something you get your daddy's name
on something you're gonna do your best
the best you can the Oklahoma Burger the
tradition of it is pickles and mustard
and fried onions that's it it's been
here since the 1920s where we believe
that the onion started right across the
street and I seasoned my grill with
pork salt
[Music]
and it gives it kind of like the old
cast iron skillet taste to it and the
slice of the onions how thin they are
you know there's Spanish yellow a little
bit sweeter they cook faster
kind of got to be careful try not to
burn them because they're cooking so
fast and one thing I think makes my
burger a little bit unique is that I I
put the bun on top of the hamburger meat
while it's cooking
I'll take it off put it on the grill and
toast it and it gives that bread kind of
a flavor to me I think a lot of little
things add up to make the burger what it
is I had a guy went to school with come
in and asked me one day said Marty how
many burgers have you cooked now I'm
talking about 52 years
I said I don't know
I figured I cook about 300 a day
times six a week times four for a month
times 12 for a year times 52.
it comes over five million hamburgers
I've cooked I'm very honored
that the Lord has given me something
that I really enjoy doing men like
George
and a patch on the back say keep going
buddy keep going
since not just sits but the seat this is
exactly where I have my first onion
burger and how long ago was this this
freaking seat right here that was a long
time ago we were younger Marty we were
younger it was a while ago yes a while
ago you know why I sat here so you can
watch exactly because I always this is
one of my favorite spots in any diner
it's right here because I get two things
I get to see what's going on I get to
talk to you people who sit here I think
get most of your attention right I
always ask how you're doing and if I
don't know I'm asking where they're from
take them how many people of my old
world yeah oh I bet yeah that's one
thing I love about this Diner you know
instead of cooking behind the wall
somewhere and then I can talk to people
around sure absolutely and you can't
hide anything no yeah
what you see is what you get that's
right I'm gonna place the order here
ready yeah right here let's do it we
need two Onion Burgers 20 tomato lettuce
or anything like that just just fried
onions no sir just the pickles on the
side right so we get to watch now yeah
this is one of the best things about
this it's a pretty substantial Patty oh
should we just did there I love that he
warmed up the spatch a little bit a lot
of onions oh that's about a minute say
oh that's so much that's it that's the
door's remote oh you know why now you
know I do that you put salt and Pepper's
half and half okay oh bottom first
always tops themes yeah I like my bread
toasted a little bit yeah okay yeah and
most people when they cook them they
just started bun on top of the meat
steam it that's what I do yeah that's
good it's all right that's how we cooked
them in the old days too yeah the first
time I came here I think you told me the
traditional way is to get no cheese you
know just fried onions pickles and
mustard okay tradition I mean that's
what I'm talking about but it's perfect
look at how perfect that that is but
Marty you have these made for you the uh
the trowel the spatula I make them you
make them you actually you cut them down
yourself yeah from what from from a
breakfast yeah
put concrete on I love seeing these you
know
you smell the the amount of onions
that's in this look at that perfectly
toasted thank you Marty
[Music]
man man that smells so good smells so
good that bun is perfectly warmed
through oh cheers bam we did it made it
oh
that's perfect perfect here Marty oh
the crunch the softness of the bottom oh
man and this is a real hamburger pickle
it's not like fancy it's not too sweet
kind of an ugly thing got the onions
hanging off of it but anyway that's the
Oaky Burger wow that's fantastic well
our first time we ever met
he showed me how to make one of these
things yeah I love making this burger
five years later this has become like
the most
iconic trendy style burger smashing
onions into a burger I mean and this is
the original to me I like taking that
Burger off that Grill and eating it
right to you yeah so this burger has now
been replicated all over the globe
people need to come here and eat this
and know where it came from or how it
started or at least what it should
really taste like can I get you anything
else
good I gotta go what else is there gotta
go chairs Marty thank you so much
ma'am of all the burgers that we've had
together whether it's Louie's lunch or
Shady igliner yeah you know going to
herds tasting the original fried onion
burger seeing all the great people that
eat here and people who make the food
it's definitely life-changing it's
life-changing and I can see why this is
the burger that you chose to master
this is only one of the three places
right you know that right yeah they're
the younger ones they've been around the
at least amount of time 1986 but you're
gonna have the street there's Roberts
only a block away from Saw driving yeah
there's a block there on that is
basically Johnny's and each one of these
places has some connection to the
history of this program speaking of
History
important to set the record straight
sometimes erroneously referred to as the
depression Burger the fried onion burger
was invented seven years before the
Great Depression in El Reno Oklahoma as
a result of the great Railroad Strike of
1922 also known as the railway shopman
strike 400 000 Railway men Nationwide
walked off the job on July 1st 1922
after the railroads threatened to cut
their pay a guy named Ross Davis had a
new burger joint called Hamburger Inn
and decided to press a large wad of thin
sliced onions into a burger patty as a
way to extend his beef supply for the
day onions were cheap flavorful and
already in use on Burgers When Ross
increased the quantity of onions to half
the Burger's volume he inadvertently
invented an instant classic
the tiny Hamburger Inn sat at a trolley
stop in the center of town and the
intoxicating smell of onions often lured
customers off the trolley into the
walk-up window 100 years later the
Hamburger Inn is long gone but the onion
burger Legacy is stronger than ever and
lives on at a number of Burger counters
in El Reno today
unquestionable Marty is one of my
hamburger Heroes I can see why you can
see why I mean obviously right it's cool
to be like the burger guy but on my
regular nine to five I'm I'm him exactly
and to see a glimpse of
how it is to just be a legend yeah
hard for it yeah he opened this place
literally to preserve history yeah this
moment sitting right here has somehow
led to me opening a restaurant this year
yeah you're a spot that's ridiculous
what I'm trying to do is respect the
craft and the history of the Oklahoma
yeah inverter let's keep it going yep
we'll invite him to the restaurant you
know sure because people understand like
I'm sure I know how to make a hamburger
but this guy is really the one the oh
gee yeah you know yeah that's why I
wanted to make sure you bet him to do
that you see now this is a connection
yeah it's like it's like shaking
Sinatra's hand there you go yeah yeah
that's that's the way it feels dude it's
like in this bird this really small
Burger community on Mars yeah it's full
of you know Legend like that I'm so
happy you made it here I'm so dude from
season one when you made it at your
house yeah that's right yeah
now we come a long way come a long way
yeah and it's all because of this one
yeah
we did it this is real Burger bucket
list thank you for taking care my
pleasure that was awesome my pleasure
it's over for the camera it's over for
the camera we've got more Burgers to eat
you best believe I'm eating more Burgers
here when this is shut up
Burger bucket list
we're out
good
[Applause]
hi George I want to see you do this at
your time
make a lot of noise
yeah I like them on the outside
[Music]
so I saw you did it like this where you
put this back on right you did that
[Music]
and this is the RV that's falling apart
Jesus Christ
I think they're sad farewell to me
sleep beneath the stars in California
foreign
[Music]
hello Internet it's your boy Alvin kylon
make sure you hit that like button smash
that subscribe button ring that
notification Bell if not for me
for the burgers
this show that show him the wine